it's I'm still figuring out as I go you
know I'm trying to do try not screw it
up
hoping that I'm still very much clay but
it's good to know we're doing what we
can't every one's working really hard
spirits are high
everyone seems to be really inspired if
you like Susan who is on par with one or
just kind of soaring I I think I don't
know I think it's uh I guess what the
wait and see you might see the finished
product but I think it's definitely it's
different
we're defecating ourselves in a good way
and I think we're going to be surprised
and I'm very curious to see the response
so yeah everyone trying to figure out
how am I going to be incorporated it
just going to be through voiceover if
we're going to have to see if we going
to see and you know I was curious there
was a poll that came out that said when
the show premiered there was a rise in
clicked on suicide prevention and also
how to commit suicide how do you feel
that your about the dialogue won both
ways that you guys are creating well I
think that the reason I I feel very
honored is because I mean as an actor
like you never really can do projects
that save a lot you're not saving lives
but but sometimes maybe you can get a
little close to the project and I feel
like we have really helped some people
and the fact that such an important
topic has become like a mainstream
worldwide topic of conversation that's
amazing that's honestly exactly what
everyone was trying to do naturally
there's going to be bad and good because
it's all based on opinion and based on
how people how it affects people and
it's never going to be 100% positive and
we knew that I was surprised it took so
long that people really kind of started
to talk in other ways about it so I
don't know it's necessary to have it's
because it starts an argument and it
starts a real discussion so I think it's
necessary to have positive
and everyone will have it on take one
last thing I'll say one negative Emmy
snub we were so fat you guys gonna get
how are you feeling about that I forgot
about it honestly I love you I don't
know
fine specific maybe a Golden Globe from
this organization that we're here today
to honor maybe so I mean if not still
cool I'm still just happy to be
presenting our grant tonight so I don't
really pay attention someone's gonna
have to inform me after they're already
announced anything happen so fine